hello everyone and welcome to another
spectacular game you guys requested it's
from round five of the meltwater
champions chester finals and it's chakra
mamidarov versus vladislav artemyev this
is game two of their match and that's
important to
know while watching this game because a
lot of decisions that happen in this
game are reflected what happened in game
one in game one artemia won a very nice
game uh and now uh mamidarov has the
white pieces and he needs to equalize
the bonds back in the match so that
being said uh let's check it out it's
one of those uh disgustingly beautiful
games uh so let's see what happens so uh
mamidarov with the white pieces opens
with e4 we have c6 artemia goes for the
karo khan defense we have d4 d5 and
mamidarov goes for the advanced
variation of the karo khan
not allowing any any early trades we
have bishop to f5 developing that light
square bishop we would very much enjoy
playing e6 so we don't have problems
developing it later on uh and g4 mommy
java goes for the very sharp bayonet
attack uh bishop back to d7 you could
also play bishop to g6 then we kind of
go into the main line where this bishop
will be harassed for quite a while but
butcher back to the by artemiv and now
c4
we have e6 the downside of this retreat
is that now you have your light square
bishop inside of your light square pawn
chain uh so you might have some troubles
developing it later on but not if you
know what you're doing so knight's the
c3 and c5 now of course we have to waste
the tempo here uh to uh put a lot of
pressure on white's center and now uh
there is a game where c captures and d5
was played it's a very well known game
between alexei sure and vishwanathan and
anando was able to win that game it was
from the 2011 leon masters
but here we have knight to f3 and it's
already as of move 7 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
artemiev continues knight the c6 puts
more pressure on the center here and the
bishop to g2 mommy jarv does not want to
uh ruin that uh tension in the center
but uh artemiev does he ha he already
won game one uh and he wants to go for
some trades here and uh simplify the
position so c captures on d4 knight
captures on d4 we have d captures and c
for knight captures and c6 bishop
captures and the bishop captures with
check we have b captures uh and now what
do you play here well trading queens
you're already down a point in the match
it's not a very ambitious move so queen
a4 makes sense we go after the c6 pawn
uh it would be very good if we could
capture this so rook the c8 artemia
defends it and he offers the a7 pawn he
needs to
hurry up with the development and well
the price of one pawn is not a lot to
pay for that so momidaro grabs it and
the queen captures an a7 and now bishop
to b4 now you you can play knight to e7
castle and you're gonna have a very nice
game uh mommy there of castle's king
side and now knight to e7 and here
bishop the g5 this is a this is a
beautiful move because it um
kind of prevents black from castling
right away
even though the knight on e7 is defended
by the bishop and by the queen so you're
not going to win any material still if
you castle rook after d1 can be very
annoying it's not at all clear what to
do here and sure okay black can play
this there are many moves you can play
like rook to c7 rook to a8 you could
even place the queen on e8 but it does
look like a white is dictating the tone
of the battle so instead after bishop g5
we have rook to a8 chasing away
mamadiarov's
we have queen backed
e3
uh and now okay instead of queen to e3
you could also trade here bishop
captures on e7 then we can't really
capture with the queen because the rook
hangs but the bishop captures is always
possible and after queen to b7 we can
just castle and now if queen captures on
c6 let's say queen b8 and black has very
nice counter play here uh you are down
upon for the moment but you will
very soon reclaim it and your pieces are
very very active so instead we have
queen back to e3
and now queen to b8 i'm pinning and now
we are ready to castle so here uh
mamijarov again who is down a point
after losing the first game uh goes
knight to e4 and now what is the meaning
behind this move why is he offering this
amazing e5 pawn uh can this pawn be
captured uh the the fact of the matter
is yes the pawn can be captured but it's
a very very complicated move um
and uh
i think for not for the reason that it's
complicated but because artemis is
already up a point in the match he
decides against it he doesn't go queen
captures an e5 he plays knight to d5 uh
but we're going to show why queen
captures an e5 is so dangerous the
problem is now you can play e3 a3 and
that's the point of moving the knight
you want to play a3 without allowing
black the option of just capturing the
knight on c3 so now uh the bishop has to
move but the bishop doesn't really have
all that many great squares the bishop
has to keep an eye on the knight here so
here we would see knight the d5
attacking white's queen and only after
the queen moves uh bishop back to a7 now
we would see another trait we would see
queen captures on c4 putting pressure on
the c6 pawn and now
black would just castle and this is what
would happen but like i said it's really
really complicated and it's a rapid game
you don't have a lot of time to
calculate all of this out for example
captures captures and f4 and then white
gets to play this position the material
is completely equal
but the white king being
open as it is black should have the
advantage here
so that's uh what uh
mamidorov is offering by playing knight
the e4 but i think artemis as he's
already uh a point in the match uh uh
refrains from from such a complication
so here he goes knight to d5 right away
attacks the queen queen to d4 and now he
castles the safety uh and now you don't
uh uh capture right away first rook
after c1 there's no rush uh but now c5
by artemia forcing mamadirov to capture
with the queen so queen captures on c4
and now queen captures an e5 and this is
a shame for white uh this was a really
wonderful pawn that really
prevented black from from doing really
whatever here uh so now a3 we can
finally play this and the queen captures
on b2 queen capture some b2 is basically
a draw offer from artemia
and it we kind of have this feeling that
artemis keeps playing this game with the
black pieces for a draw uh point is if
now rook attacks the queen for example
rook c to b1 we can play queen back to
e5 and now f4 uh what do you play uh
for the moment the bishop could not be
captured because then the the rook and
queen attack the a1 square but now after
f4 you have to do some trades for
example knight captures on f4 bishop
captures queen captures and now we can
finally play captures on b4 where white
is up a piece but black would have this
check for example and after king f2 you
will always have uh some perpetual
motives and it's very unlikely that this
would end any other way so this is what
um artemia wants with the queen captures
and b2 move but momidarov uh doesn't he
plays knight captures on c5 uh and this
is not good for white but mamadou really
wants to win and get back into the game
so bishop captures on c5 queen captures
on c5 and now h6 artemy have created
some breeding room for the king so now
you can start activating your rooks and
you also want to get rid of this bishop
from here so bishop to h4
and now there are many ways for black to
continue this game because black is much
better you could go for some rook f to
c8 ideas allow whites to give up the
queen for two rooks but it doesn't
matter black will always be better here
you could go go for knight to f4 to
activate the knight uh go for some
knight d3 idiots attacking the queen the
rook they have two pawn so many things
are possible here but uh artemis chooses
the absolute worst move he plays rook to
a4 uh and it seems like a reasonable
plan you're attacking the g4 pawn uh
it's a very nice move that activates the
rook but it's also a move that uh just
uh hands over the game to mommy thereof
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this incredible movement thereof
spotted
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations and always always
always uh looking uh for a way to
sacrifice your queen and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show of
course it's queen captures an f8 that's
the
that's the good stuff that we had to
realize that now the king will be taken
away from the safety of the h7 square
and also the bishop still covers e7 so
the h6 move didn't really do all that
much uh and here okay you could move the
king then we play queen captures on f7
and we're just uh up uh uh per rook of
course to completely winning for for
white but artemis said all right i'm
going to go down in style i'm going to
accept the queen sacrifice and now mommy
thereof just delivered rook to c8 and
this is now checkmate the king has no
squares e7 is covered by the bishop you
can't block check and that's it
so really an amazing game that really
shows you how um
if this you know if it was a single game
if artemia wasn't already leading by by
one point uh he probably would have
chosen many different paths here but
here it it just seems like uh he wanted
to trade on trade on trade down and draw
his game with black and then again play
for for something with the white pieces
but uh chess it does not work like that
and chess will always punish you if you
try um you know that that kind of an
approach uh sometimes it pays off most
of the times it doesn't as uh in chess
is in life if for a fortune always
favors the the brave and the bold
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for suggesting such
a such a lovely game uh in the end uh
artemis still won the match uh game
three was wrong and then he was able to
win game four so it's artemiev who uh
celebrates a victory here in his match
against shakhtar mamidor but he did get
this beautiful win with a queen
sacrifice uh on f8
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to wish a
happy birthday to jorge caso i hope you
had a good one and that you will have
many more uh filled with joy and chess
uh and i would like to thank my parents
for creating me drove single uh andre
frantischek and balkovich enterprises
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this amazing
event uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world thank you i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day